je vous propose de partir à la rencontre
de monsieur bruno qui donc est vers le
directeur de la pharmacie delpech ces
voix un petit peu qu'avec elle est
chapeautée ça est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer comment ça c'est fait ce que
c'est vous qui vous est proposé ce que
cela mérite paris qui vous a demandé
alors ni l'un ni l'autre
en fait nous notre travail c'est de
travailler sur les clandestins
d'officines pour faire des préparations
magistrales
les pharmaciens ont l'habitude de faire
appel à denis faut déjà faire de la
préparation alors pas du tout solution
hydroalcoolique puisque ça il ya un mois
on n'en faisait pas du coup c'était pas
du tout
or yat-il méforme ou même s en sortir ou
chanter pour diriger cette formule pour
pallier les pénuries jane et combattre
l'épidémie de couronnes à des russes
beaucoup de 6 ans pharmacien qui vous
demandez est ce que vous êtes capable de
temps cette préparation pour nous donc
on a commencé à le faire selon un
process pharmaceutique au départ au
préparatoires comme toutes les
préparations pour faisait puis très vite
ça s'emballe et on est passé de dizaines
de livres des centaines d'unités à des
milliers d'autres événements qu'on va
faire à peu près dix minutes par jour ce
qui correspond à cent mille doses
individuelles au déboiser ce
préparatoire
ensuite on a fait ça dans un local qui
nous sert de réception de matières
premières et de quarantaine et de
stockage donc là c'était pour avoir des
conditions un peu plus spacieuse et très
vite on a été aussi d'avoir dénonce
locale donc on a commencé à stocker un
peu sur la rue des bidons vides de
matériel qu'ils savaient plus et la
mairie la préfecture
sachant qu'on fabriquait la solution
drogue grippe nous ont téléphoné en nous
demandant qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour vous aider
finalement c'est la préfecture la mairie
qui nous ont permis qui veut proposer
qui nous ont permis de barrer la rue et
donc voilà ça se fait naturellement
c'est le coup signés
bones une bonne harmonie entre entre la
préfecture de police qui est de l'autre
côté du pont entre la mairie de paris de
maire du 6ème et voilà les services de
police qui viennent régulièrement et
tout se passe bien et se passe pour le
mieux dans des situations qui reste très
dégradé mais qui sous peine assez
efficace alors la destination de tout ça
est ce que c'est pour la région
parisienne pour toute la france c'est
beaucoup d'internautes qui nous pose la
question mais non c'est toute la france
alors forcément quand même le nord de la
france et après dans les gens qui
viennent ici c'est essentiellement des
pharmaciens d'officine ses terres nos
clients habituels du préparatoire gêne
ici au chaland ils repartent avec 5 10
25 solution hydroalcoolique pour après
reconditionnés ça dans leur officine
pour leurs patients est de plus en plus
on a les hôpitaux on a les forces de
l'ordre et les services de secours quels
qu'ils soient
les maisons de retraite les ehpad
donc ça c'est vraiment le gros bras sont
au pôle santé nous un peu on est les
logisticiens c'est à dire que comme a
dit le président on est
on est en guerre on allait on a les
soignants les affirmé le médecin un aide
soignant qui sont au front et qui se bat
contre l'épidémie et nous en fait notre
robin c'est d'amener à ces gens là j'ai
moins une protection pour pouvoir se
protéger
viveris donc c'est la logistique pour
réduire ces du soutien du soutien des
forces et les a très bien alors joint
que vous mettez un peu la main à la pâte
est ce que vous pourriez m'expliquer les
différentes étapes de production parce
que c'est impressionnant de voir que
tout est fait en quelques mètres carrés
du de la création au transport permet
non c'est là où il est fort c'est qu'on
est très bien organisé et on est là des
locaux qui sont très très grands de la
pharmacie en confiance la demande
dépasse par une organisation qui est
très réfléchi quand en fait là bas
le décret mandarine les matières
premières sont d'échangés et donc faut
s'accrocher si vous voulez passer l'âge
où on va commencer à faire le mélange
dans des coupes on va mélanger dans les
coudes à peu près en 2008
donc on mélange tout c'est sûr qu'il ya
de l'alcool de la colle en 96 degré ça
c'est important 130 de l'alcool un petit
train type alcoolique très élevé parce
qu'en fait c'est une séparation qui est
certes à faire donc on pouvait la faire
chez soi dans l'absolu mais ce qui est
très important c'est de partir d'une
matières premières qui tendent à se
trouver plus ferme atypique et surtout
altérité des puisqu'on va mélanger l'eau
la glycérine et d'eau oxygénée que sont
les autres constituants de la formule
oms on va baisser titre alcoolique et
pour que la solution soit efficace il
faut qu'on soit tu feras politique qui
soit aux alentours de 80 degrés si on
part de l'apple qu'on al'habitude de ce
présent commerce ou là comme modifier
les six bons jaune c'est la paix à 310
si on rajoute l'eau la glycérine et tout
ça on va avoir un petit trafic qui va
être trop faible et on a peur on n'aura
pas la mission sacrée s'il pouvait
réussir ce qui importe aussi vous faites
chez vous c'est très simple à faire
mais par contre soyez extrêmement
originaux à partir à un alcool de 96 de
vrai et si vous n'avez pas 96 devrait en
tout cas pas en dessous de 90 milles 90
vous aurez une impression d'efficacité
pour a été votre pas du tout protégé
on peut suivre une pub
on a commencé à mettre l'alcool donc on
a une conque l'alcool c'est l'ébullition
et cellulaire
ok
d'être d'être repris par veolia et
puisqu'on travaille aussi en partenariat
avec deux guerres il ya plein de tours
que ce camp c'est ce qui nous aide une
en l'occurrence c'est veolia qui
viennent nous chercher une fois par
semaine les filles vide pour après les
faire partir en commet en destruction et
donc on a des groupes qui sont des
pompes spéciale des pompes prévu
spécialement pour l'alcool donc on
remplit ici les différentes composantes
de nos besoins on mélange tout ça mais
après ça va dans les deux camions qui
sont ici et c'est calme on l'a en fait
la bonne idée promue et qu'est ce qui se
passe en france mais aussi dans le monde
sait qu'on a fixés initialement on a
plus de bouteille c'est un des problèmes
aussi une des raisons de la pénurie
c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez de
bouteilles disponibles
le nouveau fait idée qu'on a eu c'est
aussi la force du réseau
enfin souhaité qu'au final c'est que on
est en permanence au contact des gens et
l'idée c'est de dire aux revenus avec
vos flacons vides et nouveau rang si vos
flaconnage c'est à dire que déjà ces
vertueux parce que ça évite de ce fait
de bouteilles en pet est en permanence
et on pallie la pénurie de flacons en
remplissant à nouveau les féconder donc
c'est important de faire de faire passer
le message aussi jetez pas vos flacons
de gel hydroalcoolique peut-être même
donné les des pharmacies près de chez
vous quoi le pharmacien récupérera pas
du fait on pour les données adaptation
bien remplie vous d'accord mais on va
pas garder on va pas recyclés ni même
les flacons en terre qui a tenu après
c'est dans la tête du pharmacien il ya
quand même une traçabilité une commande
propreté à garder sur les matières
premières et les conditionnements donc
le pharmacien vous reprendra pas un vrai
convient de vous en rendre à pains au
style de race et ils vont empirer vous
redonnera peut être d'accord voilà et la
bonne idée de ponnat dans ses camions
c'est de dire on va s'approcher que vous
le fait de dire comment faire pour
pallier la pénurie de faire connaître
mais en fait quelque chose
assez facilement encore en france et
puisque etc
où l'écurie dans l'autre on se dit ça va
mais ton assuré qu'ils aient réussi dans
ces communes comme ça qu'on révélateur
maurice de satonnay
vous voyez c'est quelque chose qui
tourne à la farce portable c'est à dire
qu'on peut pas l'utiliser à son frein et
alors ça passe directement chez les ch
et les équipements qui en ont besoin
enfin ça qui va avoir besoin de dix huit
de manitou on va lui donner un gros qi
d'un client institutionnel qui va avoir
besoin à se disent par exemple ou un
service de police ou des who ont
travaillé avec le syndicat de la
boulangerie l'habitude qui ont besoin
d'une palette avec 500 litres
mais bon on va pouvoir faire une palette
et comme ça sa partie rapporte une règle
le problème de fonctionnement avec sa
copie donc face et lolo des pharmaciens
avaient pour demain pour montrer
massicot national les pharmaciens du
faucon traitement
complètement intégré
investis dans cette mission alors on a
pas mal de questions notamment ses mari
qui ne la pose combien de temps ça prend
ce processus de création est pour vous
de la production à la livraison
alors dans la journée au fil des minutes
c'est à dire qu'on va réceptionner
l'alcool l'un à temps de chargement
d'alcool qui peut arriver dans la
demi-heure qui arrive cet alcool
s'il arrivait le matin l'odeur le soir
et par pierre partir et on a des
encore une fois on est hyper bien
organisée c'est vraiment notre offre et
ce qui va arriver là et c'est dans la
journée et devaient repartir le soir
c'est à dire que quasiment la peta qui
arrivé ce matin peut finir le soir dans
votre poche d'accord alors est-ce que
vous pourrez continuer de m'expliquer ce
processus de création on a vu donc là
bas la première étape le mélange du fait
que le mélange effet on vient armes et
les ib cbc des camions et après donc là
vous aviez parlé de le cap on tue pas
enlever le carton comme ça on va voir
merci beaucoup d'importance qu'on fait
travailler deux partis locaux là ça
suffit pas en fait c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment des machines qui savent au
départ à faire du jus de fruits vont pas
faire remplir les écoles seulement qu'il
a fait marcher la machine
vous enlevez car on peut très bien
bc des besoins qui sont propres là on
avait quelques fonds 5 sur ce caillou
cédé 5,8 sur d'autres calmants cd dit
comme ça on n'a pas de changement dans
la sphère pour une fois on cherche à
gagner en efficacité et les gones
avaient un camion il faut les changer de
format cela prenait du temps et on
préfère prendre un deuxième camion pour
vraiment adhéré au cadeau d'arrivée à
pallier la rupture des industriels un
principal ne sait pas qui est
intéressante mais il arrive à produire
suffisamment par rapport à la demande et
donc vraiment notre rôle aujourd'hui est
de faire le la zone tampon pour que nous
disent qu elle arrive à reprendre des
classiques d'amiante apporte donc la
demande pressante et aucun niveau
lorsque la demande sans avec passion
aujourd'hui l'offre est en adéquation
avec la demande ya beaucoup de coupe de
monde de la part d
des patients que boss de la part des
industriels de faire efficace qu'on
arrive à donner le maximum de produits
avec des process qui sont certes
dégradées mais qui en poissons sont
fantastiques c'est à dire que la
préparation qui sort elle elle est
conforme aux spécifications de ms et le
problème de salle de tapoter ya pas de
problème de stabilité il n'y a pas de
problème de circulation qui est efficace
efficace en termes de gains d'efficacité
produit équivalent en termes de cadence
on arrive à les sortir on va vite et
c'est ce qu'il faut c'est arrivé à
donner aux gens des solutions de rôles
comiques le temps que les industriels et
tape très fort tous les français notre
ici sont complètement vécu dans cette
maison
alors comment ça fonctionne en terme de
deux fournisseurs qui vous travaillez
comment ça se passe me disiez vous
attendiez à une cargaison d'alcool du
coup comment ça fonctionne comment ça
s'est mis en place ces averses et vidéo
tout début de cette histoire d un qui
est à peu près un mois après avec les
connaisseurs officielle historique de la
pharmacie et ses fournisseurs de la
pharmacie vous avez pas du tout les
débits prégnon à bouger parce qu'ils
sont
les avais pas du tout les débits dont on
a des bleus rentrent pour faire dix
minutes par jour donc nous ça fait
maintenant deux semaines début de
semaine deux semaines et demie bon
un nouveau décret qui nous a permis à
nous faire matière de conflit près tous
les canaux possibles c'est pareil de
d'accéder à des alcooliers et l'alcool
c'est pas ce qui manque en france si on
a des producteurs d'alcool et c'est une
matière première qui est qui est très
disques de freins qui est facilement
disponible
donc maintenant on a une dizaine
d'ateliers qui se proposent pour rob
servir les pharmacies françaises et
l'autre avec principalement avec 3 et
ces gens là sont capables de fournir
plus de dix minutes d'appels par jour
sans aucun problème c'est le le facteur
limitant aujourd'hui n'est plus les plus
la quantité d'alcool fort
alors on voit des hommes expliqué tout à
l'heure que les tentes convoi elles ont
été fournis par la mairie de paris
est ce que vous pourriez m'expliquer ça
c'est des questions qu'on a notamment
sur sur twitch comment ça s'est mis en
place commencent à s'organiser comment
les collaborations sont faites alors
c'est très simple c'est que maire du
6ème monsieur l'époque est venu visiter
le sud comme la personnalité et entend
une fois tous à la préfecture la mairie
tous ces gens là nous demande qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour
nous aider c'est vrai que les tentes
dans le coin tu en as de la chance avec
un jour pousser vos que n'a pas vu ou de
plus mais on est toujours dans la
prévision de ce qui pourrait se passer
et donc et enfin c'est en prévision de
la santé riz pour pouvoir stocker la
pollution notant que les clients
viennent la récupérer
donc c'est vrai tous les temps tu sais
c'est le fait de rencontrer les gens et
de dire qu'est ce que tu as besoin pour
que je t'aime j'ai besoin de ça aux
cubains un inspecteur de faire l'annoncé
ça se passe comme ça aujourd'hui on a
trois tentes si demain on en a besoin
d'autres il suffit d'envoyer un mail la
préfecture ou la mairie et on aura
d'autres tentent le drapeau serbe ou
d'amérique qui vous m'en passer je
reviendrai quand on est on
un point d'appui pour l'espagne ans qui
sont qui sont en premières livres et
c'est vraiment une base logistique et de
soutien sur tous ces gens là qui sont
vraiment au contact c'est un cas d'école
est ce que vous êtes les seuls en france
à avoir fait cette entreprise là où est
ce que vous savez si en province par
exemple ça a été fait également les
pharmaciens d'officine
on estime que c'est des chiffres on n'a
pas encore les chiffres vraiment chacun
et la tête du guidon
on verra à la fin et puis c'est quoi
mais si qu'à peu près un pharmacien sur
deux fabrique lui-même sa solution
c'est à dire que le fonds sera
évidemment pas dans des rues mais qui
concerne en retrait par rapport comme si
c'est une préparation classique même si
là on n'est pas sur un médicament en
train de faire un produit bio si donc
c'est pas du tout un médicament
donc après un passage sur deux fabriques
sa solution durable public dans son
officine et l'adhésion à ses passions
après voir mon métier c'est je fais des
préparations magistrales aura pas
expliqué aujourd'hui ce que c'est que
préparations magistrales ni en double ça
nous manquait mans qui reste sur mesure
vraiment présente une adaptation de
posologie pour un enfant on va faire
exactement la dose dont a besoin un
enfant quand il ya un problème on est
une quarantaine en france à faire ça et
tous les autres sous traitants ce sont
sont dans cette aventure aussi alors
cette échelle là parce que parce que
déjà nous on est des cours de tous les
sous traitants français mais tous les
sous traitants français que ce soit à
marseille à deux des nappes est douce et
un côté de nyon à nancy à rennes je veux
pas tous ces sites est passé en
quarantaine mais voilà tout son son
fabriquer plusieurs centaines de litres
voire milliers dit par jour est répartie
third ans
les secteurs qui leur manquent pas
d'accord est ce que vous pourriez
m'expliquer un petit peu après comment
ça se passe au niveau de la préparation
pour le transport comme enlever un peu
la dernière étape quoi s'attend défini
et la ballade de l'expression qu'on
puisse les filmer a pas remis
il ya des policiers qui viennent
chercher de la solution devant le coni
pour les équipages de police puisque un
bon complément autant d'espagnols
on arrive à peu près à les fournir
autant ce qu'ils pensent de leurs skis
et ski et 10 et sur les forces de
l'ordre ils ont un manque cruel de masse
mais il arrive d une palette très
prudents ils ont pas de solution pour le
pôle inbox et non là en fait la
préfecture de police
nous les envoie en armes les équipages
dessous de son joli couple a vu ses
loyers
donc ça se passe comme ça c'est à dire
que c'est sûr que sur tablette et sur
palettes
les pignons vienne les chercher ça monte
dans les camions ou dans des véhicules
personnels et après safar sa part sur
marcher deux ou seulement aux chalands
issus et damien et où il parle
directement avec le corps de l'enfant
commence mais on peut découvrir qu'on
est con et expédier ces défis bleus on
avait reconditionnés d'étudier et les
fûts sont partis du côté de nantes
d'accord j'ai une dernière question dans
cette période où le gel hydro alcoolique
et un peu c'est un peu de l'or en barre
c'est un peu du pétrole comment est-ce
que c'est organisé niveau de la sécurité
pour sécuriser le site et notamment au
delà même des risques d'intrusions
extérieures les mêmes les risques
sanitaires et les risques aussi
d'explosion ou de protections les plus
appréciés des questions
10 et surtout de grands moments dans la
journée voyez avec mon relativement
nombreux sur le site on est à peu près
une dizaine à travailler et toute la
journée il ya défense des gens qui t'ont
déjà 4/15 équipage de police présents
sur le site soit pour récupérer de la
solution soit pour voir tout ce passe
bien on a une vraie présence policière
qui est importante sur secteur et après
la nuit
il ya en permanence de gardes dans un
maître chien pour assurer et 5 m d'euros
il ya deux personnalités de personnes
qui vont
regardez le site de
alors franchement que les risques que
vous avez cités l'onatra vous avez parlé
de risque en vaut deux vols le risque
sanitaire et de risque d'incendié ou
d'explosion parce que la halle pas ça
n'explose pas sa politique
le risque sanitaire il est complètement
maîtrisé parce que même si on en fait
une rue on reste sur des process
pharmaceutique sur des produits qui sont
pas sensibles en tant que tel parce que
ça reste de l'alcool donc il ya du lourd
donc le risque développement bactérien
et le minime et comme la même il
existerait il ya une telle consommation
en train de se faire aujourd'hui sera
dans deux trois jours toute façon
utilisée il ya pas qu tendu décidé de
mandater rien risque sanitaire n'est pas
de risque sanitaire
le risque le risque de vol entre dit
mais je m'en fiche un peu
c'est à dire que si demain il ya il ya
un gars qui viennent avec avec un
couteau pour voler ligue 2
d'alcool ils vont de la poste joue pas
je veux pas risquer ma vie n'est celle
de mes collègues pour philippe d'apple
et après le risque incendie
eh ben on fait
possible avait précédemment
dégradée lorsque les incendies d'alcool
après les raisons de cette année tout
seul tout seul comme ça c'est forcément
tout flamme
un autre coup d'électricité statique sur
les idées c
stop surtout restons dans la saison 4
débute avec on stocke nos réserves
d'alcool qui sont qu'ils sont
ils peuvent être importantes puisque 1
fui a ni baisser ça peut très mini qu on
est ceinture de bidons de 200 litres
d'eau c'est à dire que demain déjà
puisqu'on a un vrai souci de sécurité
alors moi je suis rezaï salade spp dont
peut soulager un peu de notions de la
zambie le 6 juin d'un séisme tel gpm une
zone à saint-vite qui fait que je fais
attention à ce genre de demain on va
avoir des bacs de rétention qui vont
arriver donc on aura quinze bac de
rétention qui vont arriver donc les i b
c seront sur ce bac de rétention et tout
ça sera ceinturée de mur d'eau il est
impossible demain il doit y avoir un
incendie
ra possible et fido qui brûle on est
donc on aura beaucoup d'eau qui séduira
au niveau de ton on a aussi nice a dit
souhaiter des zones de bureaux dont ceux
des bureaux avec au dessus un
appartement qui lui ôte évident
donc on a une sécurité de nos placements
on a vraiment sans oublier des sorties
tous est ignoble la sortie la sortie
principale de l'immeuble saleh de
l'autre côté de la rue si demain était
avant un incendie se serait à son volant
et si c'était ce qu'on voit c'est
l'endroit le plus le plus sécurisant
pour tout le monde et pour l'arrivée des
secours je connais juste au niveau de la
week ends à son but est juste derrière
les nôtres car je les pompiers sont
venus faire les reconnaissances eux
souffrent savoir les risques qu'ils
avaient et puis l'assaut des bureaux
d'un appartement en ville est issue de
secours de gdg pas de ce point de même
des situations très dégradée évident
qu'il doit faire une crise de crise
sanitaire et corona ghost jamais de la
vie on aurait déjà eu envie de faire ça
et jamais de la vie
une autorisation de faire ça on fait
qu'augmenter du mieux qu'on peut avec
les moyens qu'on a
et honnêtement on s'améliore tous les
jours un peu plus mais on veut
relativement serein entre les la
sécurité qu'on a misé active avec mozart
est une ode aux armes et les extincteurs
qui sont placés et les mesures
comprendront en tout cas c'est
impressionnant ça alors bien rodé on
dirait que tout est prêt depuis des
années bah non c'est alors à tous les
jours tous les jours
nous avons réfléchi on
rollot des dix est effectivement de
servir les plans national et de remplir
deux voleurs est maintenant de plus en
plus on est nombreux
c'est de se dire ok contrôle qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour améliorer toutes les
parties de toutes les parties de
du processus grand ensemble c'est
j'ai une dernière question après
l'exercice gignac est juste derrière
est ce que vous savez si au niveau
européen il ya aussi des partenariats
des échanges c'est une question de f
alors nous on a tout sur la première
fois au nom des militaires nazis belge
qui nous a demandé de la librairie
donc on n'a pas encore décidé de savoir
si on allait y faire ou à faire en tout
cas à mon niveau à moi je suis pas au
courant des changes qu'il ya avec les
pays européens sont les préparations
magistrales y en a bonstein les uns les
autres on essaie de comprendre ce qui se
fait ailleurs pour essayer d'être comme
le meilleur des uns et des autres
là on est dans une situation qui tous
les joueurs évoluent on est là je suis
focalisé sur ce que ce qui se passe chez
moi et j'ai pas le temps de regarder
ailleurs
c'est dommage parce que je suis sûr qu
ailleurs espace où des chouettes empêche
qu'on se connaît quand même relativement
unique c'est à dire que j'imagine qu'en
france il n'y a pas d'autre endroit où
l'on fait ça concerne c'est fait que ça
va donner des idées à d'autres et on me
en europe en europe peut-être on avait
la télévision russe
là on a eu la culture romaine qui moud
ça me donnera pas d'autres idées
ailleurs mais peut-être que ça se fait
je crois
merci beaucoup monsieur bruno de votre
temps si précieux et félicitations de la
part d'internautes comme objectif un
outil qui vous qui vous féliciter métier
qui vous remercie